let's say this is me and i am floating
in space
my coordinate system my frame of
reference we've seen it before we'll
call it the s frame of reference any
space in any point in space time we give
it an x and y coordinates and let's say
that we have my friend and we've we've
involved her in many other videos before
she is traveling if with a relative
velocity to me
of v
so
v right over there her frame of
reference we call it the s prime frame
of reference and you can denote any
event in space time by the coordinates x
prime
and
x prime and c t
prime now you could also do it as t
prime if you like but we've been doing
it as c t prime so that we have similar
units and let's say that we have a
third character now this is going to get
interesting let's say the third
character is traveling with the velocity
u in my frame of reference so u is equal
to change in x
over change in time
so if we know all of this information
let's see if we can come up we can
formulate a way if we know what the
change in x and change in time is
and we know what v is if we can figure
out what is this velocity going to be in
the s prime frame of reference in this
purple friends frame of reference so
what we want to figure out is what is
let me do it in that purple color
we want to figure out what is going to
be the change in x prime
over change in
t prime if we figure this out then we
know what will this velocity look like
in the s prime frame of reference
well let's just go back to the lawrence
transformations let's first think about
what our
let's first think about what change in x
prime is going to be
well our change in x prime is going to
be
the lorentz factor
times our change in x
change this in white
minus
beta
times change
in
ct
and let me close those parentheses
and then we want to divide that by our
change in time
we want to divide it by our change in
time
so change
in time
or change in t prime i should say well
let me just go back to the lorentz
transformation let me write the way that
i'm used to writing it i'm used to
writing it as
i'm used to writing it as change
in c t prime which is the same thing as
c times the change in t prime
is equal to
is equal to the lorentz factor
times
this is going to be c
change in ct or i could write it as c
change in t
minus beta
times change in
x times change in x and once again i
could have written this as change in c t
or i could write this as c times change
in t because the c isn't changing
so
we know that already so if we wanted to
solve for just change in t prime we
could just divide both sides by c so
let's do that if we divide all of this
if we divide
all of this by c
what do we get
and this is a form we've seen this in
other videos that you might recognize
and you might see this in some textbooks
our change in t prime is going to be
equal to gamma
times well c times delta t divided by c
is just going to be delta t
delta t and then if you take so minus
beta divided by c well let's just remind
ourselves that beta is equal to v over c
so beta divided by c is v over c squared
so i could write this as minus v
over c squared
change in x
so
change in t prime let's write that now
that's going to be equal to
you have your gamma
your gamma
times change in time
in my coordinate system so not the t
prime just change in t
change in t minus v over c squared
change in x
so immediately there's at least one
simplification we can do we can divide
both the numerator and the denominator
by gamma i keep wanting to change so we
can divide the numerator and denominator
by gamma that simplifies a little bit
and so we can write this as
our change in x prime
over change in t prime
is equal to
in the numerator we have change in x and
actually let me just write out what beta
is
so
beta actually let me write it over i'll
do it over here minus v
over c that's what beta is and actually
let me take the c out if change in ct is
the same thing as c times change in t
so times c
delta t
well v divided by c times c is just
going to be v so let me write it that
way so this part these cancel out this
is the same thing as change in x minus v
change in t
so let me write it just that way
simplify it so minus v
change in t that's our numerator and
then our denominator our denominator is
change in t minus v over c squared
change in x
so it looks like we're getting close
here but we we don't have the change in
x change in t we have how much change in
how much of a change in x we have for a
given change in t so what we could do is
we can divide the numerator and the
denominator by delta t
so we could multiply the numerator by
one over delta t and the denominator by
one over delta t which is equivalent to
dividing the numerator and denominator
each by delta t and why am i doing that
well if i do that
this first term right over here is going
to be delta x
over delta t which we know
and then we have minus v
minus v because delta t divided by delta
t is just going to be one and then our
denominator delta t divided by delta t
is just one and then we're going to have
minus v
minus v over
c squared and then times delta x divided
by delta t
delta x
divided by
delta t so this is cool we've just been
able to figure out what our velocity in
the primed coordinate system and the s
prime frame of references in terms of
the relative velocity between the s
prime frame of reference and my frame of
reference delta x delta t the velocity
in my frame of reference
and well we know all of this other stuff
too this is just delta x delta t and
this is v or we could even write it like
this we said delta x over delta t is
going to be equal to u so it's equal to
u
minus v
over
1 minus delta x over delta t is just u
so
this is just u here so it's u times v
u times v or v times u
all of that over c
squared so this is a really really
really useful derivation which we're
going to apply some numbers to in the in
the next video so we can appreciate
kind of how fun this is on some level